welcome to Hannity busy night tonight we
are tracking several big breaking
stories including new information on the
FISA abuse report fallout surrounding
another massive live from oh the
president calls her Pocahontas Elizabeth
Warren as she's now almost as bad at
lying as your corrupt media mob and even
the congenital liar
yeah the corrupt compromised Adam Schiff
I'm going to tell you all about a new
investigation also into creepy sleepy
quid-pro-quo Joe and a lot of details
but first in tonight's monologue we
start with a closer look at the
mainstream media mob and they are a mob
and their allies in the Democratic Party
because over the past week we have
witnessed more the same madness now
consumes pretty much 99% of media in
this country now to be a Democrat or
part of the mob there's no objective
truth in your rage Trump every second of
every day world you have to be a member
you have to have zero intellectual
honesty selective moral outrage only no
common sense no reason and breathtaking
hypocrisy now the moms mobs non-stop
coverage of the congenital liar Schiff
and his impeachment charade it wasn't
just maddening it was also full of lies
and outright propaganda misinformation
they spent an entire week digging for
evidence that doesn't just exist and
predictably breathlessly hyping up
testimony filled with let's see
conflicting confusing statements almost
all of it on hearsay conjecture and what
are people's opinions about a transcript
we don't need their interpretation
because we actually get to read it
ourselves and decide for ourselves
none of it would be admissible or ever
count in evidence in a real court of law
here is a small sample of how sick ugly
twisted and despicable they really are
take a look Trump allegedly abused his
power for private gain by pressuring
Ukraine abuse of office for Trump's
so gain at the expense of us he used the
security and the international
relationships that we are required to
have for the security of our country as
a bargaining chip for his own personal
gain
president Trump extorts a partner who's
under duress for his personal political
benefit we're talking about here is a
bribery extortion scheme whether you're
a Republican or a Democrat extortion is
extortion and bribery is bribery you're
talking about Joe oh now somehow at the
very same time these very same people
follow me here they have literally
bifurcated cut in half their brain they
have to literally shut off one half of
their brain and down play video evidence
of the real corruption that they're
acting so outraged about that in this
case has incontrovertible overwhelming
evidence in other words it really was a
quid pro quo but it was with Joe 303 303
of Ukraine and bragging about it now
you're not getting a billion dollars
unless you fire the prosecutor who's
investigating my zero experience son
Wow you're not getting the billion
unless you fire that guy because you're
investigating him there's no experience
and he's making millions and millions of
dollars now stop for a second how can
the same people all last week in the mob
and the media having the same people in
in the news industry they're journalists
be so outraged the president Trump for
doing nothing zip yet totally completely
ignored the biggest slam dunk case of
what they say that they are so outraged
about you have to ignore the
indisputable fact that hunter Biden he
was making millions of millions of
dollars serving on the board of a
corrupt Ukrainian oil and gas company
you have to ignore the fact that hunter
at zero experience in oil gas energy or
Ukraine yet have to ignore the fact that
hunter Biden was hired just weeks after
his father was appointed to lead
White House policy in Ukraine you have
to ignore the fact that Vice President
Joe Biden leverage a billion tax dollars
and bragging about it to force out a
Ukrainian prosecutor the same one
investigating his son that is all that
none of that is in dispute but the mob
and the media says this is one big this
is only a conspiracy theory nobody who's
ever really proven it
nobody's investigated it we are and
we're gonna get to the bottom of it take
a look mr. vice president president
Trump has falsely accused your son of
doing something wrong while serving on a
company board in Ukraine I want to point
out there's no evidence of wrongdoing by
either one of you there's no proof
whatsoever that Joe Biden did anything
wrong or that Hunter Biden did anything
wrong
Trump's claims about wrongdoing here are
unsubstantiated we have looked lots of
out outlets have looked Trump is making
a wholly unsubstantiated claim when he
alleges corruption by the Biden's
there's no evidence of any wrongdoing in
reality Joe Biden was the one working to
purge corruption from Ukraine and
utterly baseless theory these of the Joe
Biden there's no evidence nor has there
ever been any evidence that he was doing
anything but trying to get the Ukraine
government to crack down on corruption
leave Joe alone just leave him alone
the barista the the the Biden probe it's
a bunch of BS now that's how despicable
and corrupt the Democrats in the mob are
how is it no evidence we've all looked
if you looked and you'll hear Joe
bragging you're not getting the billion
he's leveraging their money and if you
look closer watch hunter Biden on GMA
what did he do he said no I have no
experience well once it was on a board
at Amtrak oh there's a ton of experience
this level of groupthink is not only
despicable what you just watched is
dangerous there buh-ba-ba-bah they're
losing it now I say mob and the media
for a reason they are a mob with a mob
mentality and a mob mindset they don't
care about their breathtaking
ah cracy obviously their their hatred of
Trump all that is superior to everything
else they don't care about the lies that
they're telling the propaganda they're
spreading the conspiracy theories are
spinning the hoax is that they continue
to perpetrate one right after another
after another after another because they
were in their little bubble little echo
chamber there's a whole rest of the
country that doesn't live in DC New York
LA and San Francisco and their bubble is
filled with every second minute hour of
every 24 hour day Trump rage psychosis
venom and that has resulted in this
endless stream of fake hysteria lying
propaganda misinformation smearing
slander distortion and everything in
between
they have been crying wolf for three
long years and by the way they've not
done a thing for you we the American
people not one thing have these people
done except bring us to the brink of
impeachment Wow take a look I have not
seen anything like this since October
20th 1973 when President Nixon fired
Archibald Cox Nixon Richard Nixon
Watergate echoes of Watergate a giant
step toward impeachment impeachment
impeachment impeachment impeachment
impeachment implications are now in the
air the president will be removed from
office bombshell bombshell bombshell
bombshell bombshell bombshell bombshell
bombshell bombshell stories dropping
seemingly every day he will resign the
presidency warming to the idea of his
resignation he should resign resign
presidencies the walls closing in and
his lashing out he feels the walls
closing in close you could feel the
thread being pulled you can feel the
clothes starting to come off the emperor
I believe this is the beginning of the
end
Donald Trump's done he's done there's no
question about that
selective moral outrage and that's what
the mob looks like sad it's sick it's
dangerous when the facts don't fit their
narrative they just lie they lied for
three years about Trump Russia the
collusion hoax they lied about the
allegations against justice Cavanaugh
anyone ever say they're sorry they lied
about Covington High School students
like Oh
Nicholas salmon by the way Nicholas
salmon I predict is going to be one of
the wealthiest kids in the country
pretty soon they lied about Ukraine
they're lying about the Biden's every
single day they lie when they say that
they're journalists they're not
journalists and yet they have the gall
oh they always want to criticize us look
at fake News CNN look at all their phony
reporting they're actually using well
this guy wouldn't have a job he's so bad
at TV this low rated stenographer of
Jeff Zucker their president his name is
Humpty Dumpty that's what I call he
dedicated an entire segment he doesn't
have I don't think a million viewers on
his show to his sparsely watched Sunday
show critiquing our coverage of shifts
impeachment charade calling the
Ukrainian interference in the 2016
election a conspiracy theory it's a
problem the Ukrainian Court determined
otherwise and maybe you'd want to go and
look at what Politico said on January 11
2017 and read about Alexander chalupa
Ukrainian embassy in Washington and how
successful they were at interfering
helping Hillary and trying to hurt
Donald Trump but then minutes later then
they feature a guest suggesting that
President Trump is a destructive cult
leader using mind control on his
supporters and Humpty is just one of
many of the monitors taking order from
their their leader their fearless leader
fake news chief Jeff Zucker their whole
purpose of this low-rated last-place
existence so-called news network channel
is to like attack the channels that are
successful and if it wasn't so sick it's
actually pretty funny it's very
entertaining to me in order to deflect
from their own constant lying and their
own conspiracies and their own hoaxes
well and of course their anti-trump bias
every second of the day they just lie
and more and more they they claim others
are guilty of what they do every day all
day so we've got a real crisis of
information in the country make no
mistake fake news CNN area 51 yes
Roswell Rachel Maddow is conspiracy
television network MSDN
see and whole channel that tries to
duplicate what she does they have zero
fidelity to truth zero fidelity to truth
and nothing but the truth to the rule of
law equal justice under law equal
application of their laws equal
application of standards Jo and hunter
that's why it is up to us I guess all
right I'll leave it to us the number one
show on cable news thanks to all of you
we will remind them that Ukrainian
interference in the 2016 elections
actually happened that's why we will vet
quid pro quo Jo and hunter and the rest
of the radical extreme socialist
Democratic field they'll never do it
that's why it'll be up to us to call out
yes the compromise the corrupt
congenital liar ship and the ship show
but what it really is just another
effort to smear president Trump undo a
duly elected president and by the way
we'll kick it all off with either
hearsay or opinion witnesses and a
hearsay non whistleblower whistleblower
who was communicating apparently with
chips office early on look at this
report January 2017 Washington Times
this individual might have actually
benefited from one of President Obama's
final directives Wow doing to the next
president that which you didn't want in
your administration giving
whistleblowers new protections against
the executive branch this came in the
final weeks of the Obama presidency and
as a Washington Times columnist put a
quote this is in stark contrast to when
he entered office in 2009 and Obama
waged a war against this community and
his administration prosecuted nine
whistleblowers under the 1917 Espionage
Act more than double that of all other
previous administrations combined but
the mob while President Trump is bad and
well Obama's a saint
again it's crystal clear they have an
agenda zero fidelity to truth and
unwavering allegiance to their own far
extreme left-wing socialist agenda